facebook announced friday that former
president donald trump will remain
suspended from the platform for two
years
the social media site said after two
years the company will quote
look to experts to assess whether the
risk to public safety has receded
the initial suspension came on january
7th after trump communicated with
supporters storming the capital
in may an independent oversight board
deliberated on whether the former
president should remain suspended
ultimately defending facebook's decision
but criticizing facebook for the
open-ended nature of the suspension
along with the suspension facebook
announced they will be implementing
15 of the board's 19 recommendations
including
banning high government officials for
inciting or celebrating ongoing civil
unrest and being more transparent about
their newsworthiness allowances
if after returning to the platform trump
continues to commit infractions
facebook says he will face a strict set
of rapidly escalating sanctions that
include permanent removal
you